we're gonna play a little game cool this
is very easy
it's called fill in the blank I'm gonna
set you up with a question and you just
fill it in with the first thing that
comes to mind first thing that comes to
my mind oh guys okay I would describe
season four as enthralling
America epic sausage comes to mind
the American colonies are intriguing
dangerous berry full of trees to know
what lies beyond those trees mortirolo
is the cutest when looking at my face he
has the most beautiful eye when he looks
at you please just melts hot melts brolo
is the cutest when he hits his mark
right
st. roll oh hey you're my boy the one
thing fans should know about Aunt
Jocasta is there's more to her than
meets the eye she can be a bit saucy if
you know what I mean I've been keeping
an eye on you my go-to crafty snack this
year has been protein boss Oh protein
bars spoon boom
blueberries onion salad give us a little
bit of a recipe for this to be honest we
were trying to think of something that
would confuse them that's a fine idea
the scene I'm most looking forward to
see on screen is I'm excited to see
everything we have some really really
cool things and setups
the sets are incredible and the actors
are incredible and the costumes are
incredible so I'm excited to see that
the scene I'm most looking forward to
seeing is all of the stuff in the
countryside of us writing in the horses
exploring the wilderness and building
our cabin building phrases rich this
must be the most beautiful land I've
ever seen Claire and Jamie are solid as
a rock it's great that they finally get
to be together
[Music]
[Applause]